llegamos aquí
[Música]
muy buen día con todos realmente para mí
es un gusto estar el día de hoy y
compartir nuevas ideas con relación a
cómo podemos gestionar los gobiernos de
manera más amigables para los ciudadanos
de modo tal que la palabra gobierno no
sea algo que nos ahuyenta y más bien sea
un tema que nos involucra a todos
efectivamente en la toma de decisiones
que finalmente afecta la vida de todos
en la sociedad
para hablar de gobierno abierto
necesariamente tenemos que hablar del
modo tradicional de hacer política y
para esto me voy a referir a una
publicación de oscar oszlak que en el
2013 con relación al modo tradicional de
hacer política
citaba aquella experiencia de un
gobernador de los eeuu que a su equipo
de trabajo le había señalado que nunca
pero nunca sería una buena idea publicar
un resultado propuesto junto a una fecha
pues siempre habrá una persona que
estará esperando la llegada de esa fecha
para enrostrarle que no has cumplido lo
ofrecido por lo tanto concluía para que
dar munición gratuita y efectivamente
los gobiernos se han manejado de manera
tradicional de modo tal que la
información efectivamente es poder
existen un sinnúmero de normas a nivel
internacional y nacional que en teoría
nos garantizan el acceso a la
información pública sin embargo
existe de manera general en las
instituciones públicas la creencia de
que la información generada por estas
instituciones es únicamente accesible
por parte de aquellos funcionarios
directamente involucrados con esa
información o en todo caso aún cuando
hay que publicar cierta información por
exigencia legal la calidad de su
información no siempre es la mejor y por
lo tanto nos dificulta el proceso de
entendimiento de qué es lo que están
haciendo nuestras autoridades y como
nosotros podemos reutilizar esa
información de modo tal de generar
nuevas soluciones a los problemas que
afrontamos y que son de competencia de
los niveles de gobierno en sus distintas
instancias
en relación a la participación ciudadana
los modelos de gestión pública
tradicional se centran básicamente en el
poder del voto es decir nosotros cada
cuatro años nos acercamos una a una
elegimos a nuestras autoridades y a
partir de eso nosotros no sabemos
necesariamente qué es lo que están
haciendo cómo se están disponiendo
nuestros recursos y si efectivamente en
el proceso en el cual ellos están
ejerciendo la representación de nosotros
están cumpliendo con aquellas ofertas
que hicieron durante el proceso
electoral
en tal virtud la organización de los
estados americanos ha señalado que
actualmente existen al menos tres
desafíos gubernamentales principalmente
para la región uno recobrar la confianza
en nuestras instituciones democráticas
evidentemente los escándalos de
corrupción que han surgido en los
últimos años han minado la confianza de
los ciudadanos en nuestras instituciones
democráticas no confiamos en lo que
hacen desconocemos definitivamente son
opacas y no sabemos cuáles son los
procesos por los cuales se llevan a cabo
las decisiones de las autoridades
adicionalmente sin duda el rol de las
tecnologías de la información ha sido
fundamental en estos nuevos desafíos
gubernamentales la irrupción de las
tecnologías de la información ha
facilitado el acceso de la ciudadanía a
la información pública y además en
función de eso nosotros con cierto grado
de especialización en diversos ámbitos
también tenemos interés de a través de
estas tecnologías de la información ser
partícipes de los procesos de toma
cuantos de los que estamos aquí
presentes no tenemos cierto grado de
especialización en diversas materias que
el gobierno que al gobierno le podrían
ser útiles para resolver una infinidad
de problemas que tenemos nosotros como
sociedad
finalmente el tercer desafío que
afrontamos como sociedad es el de la
escasez de recursos evidentemente hay un
proceso de crecimiento sobre todo en las
últimas décadas de crecimiento de las
urbes la migración del campo hacia la
ciudad ha generado nuevas necesidades
tenemos que dotar a la ciudadanía de
servicios básicos pero servicios de
calidad si es que nosotros desviamos los
recursos que tenemos como estado
a temas vinculados a actos de corrupción
o justamente por la ejecución de este
tipo de actos de corrupción nosotros no
captamos los tributos necesarios para
satisfacer esas necesidades jamás
estaremos en capacidad de darle a ningún
grupo humano una calidad de vida digna
para tener una referencia sobre este
último tema
transparencia internacional en el año
2018 lanzó su índice de percepción de la
corrupción se mide en 180 países el
ecuador está en el puesto 114
frente a estas
frente a estas complejidades que afronta
el sector público
que tradicionalmente se ha visto como un
esquema en el cual es una caja negra en
la cual muy poco nos importa a nosotros
los ciudadanos qué es lo que están
haciendo dentro de las cuatro paredes
las instituciones en tanto nos provean
de servicios y productos de calidad pero
con la irrupción de estas tecnologías
diferente a las nuevas necesidades que
hemos señalado y rompe una vieja nueva
idea la del gobierno abierto y el una
vieja en la vida pues en realidad la
promoción de agendas por las cuales las
entidades gubernamentales aperturen de
manera cada vez más fuerte la
información que están generando y a
partir de ello promueven la
participación no es una idea nueva de
hecho a partir de los años 60 ya se
promovía la necesidad de permitir a la
ciudadanía el acceso a la información
pública
sin embargo de manera muy general hoy en
día podemos señalar que el gobierno
abierto es un nuevo esquema de gestión
pública que se fundamenta en el
principio de transparencia de la
institución pública y de sus autoridades
a través de un constante proceso de
rendición de cuentas a la ciudadanía y
la exigencia de la ciudadanía de control
social a sus autoridades pero para que
se transparente a la gestión pública
para promover la participación de la
ciudadanía en el proceso de toma de
decisiones públicas y generar de manera
constante nuevos espacios de
colaboración donde confluyan no sólo la
administración pública para decidir
cuáles son las soluciones de nuestros
problemas sino que también contamos con
la experiencia y el conocimiento
específico de la academia del sector
productivo y de las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil para que en conjunto
decidamos cuáles son las mejores
soluciones a los problemas que
afrontamos como sociedad
les había señalado que el primer
principio sobre el cual se funda el
paradigma del gobierno abierto es el de
la transparencia
es decir el derecho a saber tenemos
derecho a saber qué es lo que están
haciendo las autoridades con nuestros
recursos
es lo que está haciendo las autoridades
en relación al cumplimiento de aquellos
ofrecimientos que hicieron durante el
proceso electoral efectivamente están
cumpliendo aquellas ofertas de campaña
existen los mecanismos idóneos para que
la ciudadanía acceda a esta información
es información que además nosotros
podemos reutilizar y darle un valor
agregado
hace unas semanas con motivo de un
encuentro en materia de gobierno abierto
un encuentro regional estábamos dándole
un poco de giro alrededor del tema de la
transparencia y generalmente el tema de
la transparencia en el paradigma del
gobierno abierto ha sido vinculado a la
necesidad de que la ciudadanía
fiscalicen los actos de sus autoridades
sin embargo la agenda de la
transparencia de la información pública
no sólo puede estar enfocada en este
sentido tiene unas 9 unos nuevos puntos
de vista que permiten a la ciudadanía a
partir de esta información pública y de
los datos que liberan las
administraciones que la ciudadanía
incluso genere de manera individual
nuevas soluciones a los problemas que
afrontamos como sociedad por ejemplo las
municipalidades en caso de liberar datos
relacionados con el sistema de
transporte público permitirían que la
academia o un grupo de emprendedores
diseñan nuevas plataformas que nos
faciliten nos permitan conocer cuando
una determinada ruta de transporte va a
pasar por la para
en mi casa y en cuánto tiempo estimó que
esa ruta de transporte llega a su
destino son algunas de las soluciones
que la transparencia de la gestión
pública ofrece a la ciudadanía
pero para que queremos transparentar la
gestión pública
la gestión pública se transparenta
porque es una condición necesaria para
que la ciudadanía participe en los temas
de interés general y queda claro que los
ciudadanos no van a participar en
aquellos temas que desconoce existen una
serie de buenas prácticas en materia de
gobierno abierto enfocados a la
participación ciudadana a nivel
internacional y hoy en día frente a los
desafíos que principalmente se
encuentran desarrollados en la agenda
2030 podemos señalar entre otros
ejemplos aquel de madrid por el cual
cualquier ciudadano a través de una
plataforma digital puede hacerle una
propuesta a la administración municipal
para que esa propuesta con un número
mínimo de respaldos de la ciudadanía sea
obligatoriamente acogida por el
ayuntamiento quien se obliga a
desarrollar el servicio propuesto por el
ciudadano la obra pública que ha sido
propuesta o incluso el desarrollo de una
normativa en función de las propuestas
de la ciudadanía que han contado con un
apoyo mínimo
de los ciudadanos
en colombia
se están desarrollando asambleas en los
cuales los gobernadores se encuentran
directamente en asambleas ciudadanas con
un grupo de representantes que
libremente acceden a las mismas para
decidir cuáles son las obras que
queremos desarrollar en determinados
sectores es decir la autoridad lo que
está haciendo es comprometer un grupo de
recursos un grupo de recursos de la de
los departamentos de colombia en
aquellas obras que la ciudadanía
libremente ha decidido que son las que
necesita la comunidad en determinado
sector ecuador no se queda atrás tenemos
una buena serie de ejemplos relacionados
con buenas prácticas en materia de
gobierno abierto enfocados a la
participación ciudadana una de ellas la
silla vacía tal vez no todos lo
conocemos pero cualquier organización de
la sociedad civil puede designar
representantes para que con voz y voto
asistan a los debates en los consejos
municipales y provinciales y puedan
proponer a nuestras autoridades política
pública en sus ámbitos
es decir tenemos como condición
necesaria para que la ciudadanía
participe siempre que transparentar
cuáles son los procesos que estamos
llevando a cabo en las instituciones
públicas de modo tal que el ciudadano
puede involucrarse y enrolarse en el
proceso de manera oportuna y no a través
de las conocidas socialización es esto
es cuando la administración pública
únicamente nos informa sin que exista
una consulta efectiva a la ciudadanía de
qué es lo que se va a hacer
finalmente
el tercer pilar sobre el cual se siente
una política de gobierno abierto es la
de la colaboración queremos
transparencia para participar pero una
vez que hemos participado que viene
queremos promover nuevos espacios en los
que efectivamente el gobierno de manera
permanente se involucre con la academia
con la sociedad civil y con las
organizaciones del sector productivo de
modo tal que en conjunto podamos
analizar y observar cuáles son los
procesos que están fallando dentro de
nuestras entidades en la ejecución de
políticas públicas proponer soluciones y
ejecutarlas
estamos convencidos para cerrar que
nuestras entidades gubernamentales
definitivamente no se pueden manejar
bajo el esquema tradicional el convenido
haciendo no podemos concebir a nuestros
gobiernos como las cajas negras en las
cuales nosotros no sabemos que están
pasando tras de esas cuatro parejas y
nosotros hoy en día contamos con
suficientes de herramientas en cualquier
país para acceder a la información
exigir a nuestras autoridades la
liberación de información y a partir de
ello nosotros en función de nuestro
conocimiento específico plantear
soluciones a los diversos problemas que
nos aquejan como sociedad en los
diversos niveles de gobierno por lo
tanto les invito a que a partir del día
de hoy
y solicitemos a nuestras autoridades sea
cual sea el nivel del gobierno apertura
de la información para que a partir de
ello nosotros podamos ser partícipes y
promover nuevos espacios en los cuales
efectivamente colaboremos y demos
seguimiento a la ejecución de políticas
públicas es la única manera en la cual
evitaremos que los recursos sean
desviados a otros fines y que
efectivamente podamos mejorar nuestras
condiciones de vida muchas gracias
y en la zona
es el tiempo
[Música]